but would I say I pray five times a day
I pray whenever I get a chance because I
can't it's it's difficult to remember I
don't speak Arabic I changed my religion
not my culture
I used to struggle reading the Quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app I never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
here is a video of a Billionaire's son
Alfie who's come to Islam and here is
the concern that he had pertaining to
Salah what is stopping him from praying
Salah and what is the solution well do
you pray
of course yeah but would I say I pray
five times a day I pray whenever I get a
chance whenever I get chance and to be
honest with you I'm not up to scratch
with it now and you know if I could pray
by myself I believe I'd pray a lot more
because I can't it's difficult to
remember I don't speak Arabic and a lot
of people that I've spoke to about it I
changed my religion not my culture yeah
now you know the the inshallah the the
simple words that come with it what you
know Western Muslims speak obviously I'm
going to pick up but the prayers from
start to finish are are difficult for me
because I don't understand I can't speak
the language But as time goes on I will
and I'm trying but yes I do pray as much
as I possibly can I go to the mosque
every Friday
no way
my way and you know what Alfie I have a
solution for you now don't feel guilty
because when I came to Islam 10 years
ago I struggled because it's hard like
you said I changed my religion not my
culture so therefore do not feel feel
blameworthy that you do not know how to
pray you cannot memorize the words
totally understandable absolutely normal
I have a solution for you our
organization which is a charity
not-for-profit organization brothers and
sisters who are watching this Alfie
please please get me in contact with
Alfie I would like to send you a free
guided prayer mat yes that teaches you
everything that you need to know and
recite and say it is right in front of
you in this prayer mat and guess what
people donate it and we give them out
for free we don't want nothing no money
no shout out nothing I'm genuinely doing
this because you want to learn how to
pray Salah I've been through that I know
how it feels the reason why because I
can see myself in you 10 years ago so I
know exactly how it feels how
frightening it was for me to go to a
mosque I don't know if it was a temple I
don't know if it was going to the right
place but it's very daunting so guess
what this guided Prema from
salahplus.com where we dedicate
ourselves to the two pillar project
which is what the shahada number one
somebody accepts Islam the second pillar
of Islam is Salah once people have these
two pillars the remaining will follow
inshallah fasting go in Hajj the main
thing now is the second pillar which is
how to pray Salah this prayer mat will
change your life Fold It Up put it in
your wallet whatever it is even in your
pocket wherever you are open it and all
you have to do is as you're looking down
you can recite it exactly that's all you
do until you memorize it once you've
done it bro put it up in your room like
a trophy alhamdulillah inshallah and
Alfie I also one of the things we do in
our organization is our one-to-one
personal training with a salon
instructor myself or somebody could come
out to you and teach you how to play
Salah step by step again we do not want
to shout out we don't want nothing from
you all we just want to do is teach you
how to pray Salah because people donated
towards this project and we are here to
make sure we deliver that promise
inshallah guys get me in contact with
Alfie please send this prayer man we
want this prayer Matt to reach Alfie I
will hand deliver it or we can post it
out directly to his address it'll be
anonymous wherever it is or I can bring
it to him myself or to one of his
friends inshallah and Salah is the
component that number one fundamental
thing that spiritually elevates you
spiritually feeds your soul everything
in life that we have that emptiness is
what because of Salah because of the
remembrance of Our Lord we give it the
money the cars the woman the holidays
and all this luxury but the heart
rejects it just like when you eat bad
food the stomach vomits it out the soul
rejects it because the soul wants the
remembrance of his Lord and what is best
then praying Salah our female Allah keep
you firmed the prayer mat is waiting for
you to be sent out directly to you and I
promise you it's going to change your
life even by yourself you can do it but
if you need a one-to-one Salas
throughout the session I am more than
happy to come and teach you how to pray
Salah inshallah may Allah preserve you
and look after yourself Alfie send this
video to him please please please just
bombard him and let it reach him
inshallah and he can go to our website
salahplus.com and so can you if you want
to learn how to pray get the prayer mat
freely distributed sent to you or you
want to learn how to pray for instructor
brother's team and sisters team we are
there to serve you
guys do not forget to donate to this
project so we can carry on our works
inshallah